MODERATOR: We are so lucky to
have Sheila Marcelo here today
to talk to us about
her company, Care.com.
She is the founder, chairwoman,
and CEO of Care.com,
and it's the largest
online destination
for finding quality care.
You can find care for children,
for seniors, and for pets.
We'll hear more
about this, but I
think you started this because
you found yourself sandwiched
between needing to take
care of young children
as well as ailing
parents, and you just
had a hard time
finding quality care
and felt like, gosh, there's
got to be a better way,
and technology has got
to be the solution here.
So I think it's a great fit for
a lot of what we care about,
as well as the technology, as
well as in our personal lives.
And you founded it in
2006, and recently took it
public this year.
So we can ask her about
that process as well.
I have to say, I'm in
the process right now
of changing my care at home.
So personally, I've got
a job open on Care.com.
For any of you that are
interested and are thinking
to yourselves, gosh,
this sounds great,
we have a Google
benefit where we
pay for a premium annual
membership for all
of our Googlers.
So just go to go/care.com
benefit if you want to check it
out.
One last thing to note
before Sheila comes up
is that we're so lucky
to have her here,
because she's someone
who's speaking at the state
level, at the country
level, in a lot of places.
She was a speaker
at Davos last year.
She also presented, alongside
President Obama this year,
on the White House Summit
for Working Families.
And she's also spoken
to heads of state
in Japan, in the Philippines.
And in Japan, there's a
real infrastructure issue
around child care there.
So she is knowledgeable not
only in running her business
and as an entrepreneur
and as a mom,
but she's knowledgeable
at the state level
as well, across the globe.
So with that, welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
SHEILA MARCELO: Thank you.
Good morning.
What do you see?
Do you see the bird,
the aspirational view
of what literally could be
the egg that the painter sees?
What do you see when you look
in the mirror in the morning?
The lion or the cat?
Might depend which
morning it is.
What do you see here?
Do you see a mother bird
feeding her chicks in the nest,
or do you see a pensive woman?
Why am I showing
you these images?
Because it's illustrating
a simple fact--
you actually see
what you want to see,
or what you're
programmed to see.
We're going to talk a little bit
about the brain this morning,
and why it matters.
Because first,
I'm going to start
to share some of my own stories.
You're seeing a CEO,
founder, chairwoman.
Thank you for the introduction.
You've got context of who I am.
But what if you don't
have the context?
I'll share three quick stories.
One morning, I got up, I went
downstairs to the refrigerator,
I opened it to go look for
eggs, milk-- typical weekend--
and decided I was going to
run to the grocery store,
because we didn't have any.
And I decided I wasn't
going to put any makeup on.
I was just going to put
my hair up on a ponytail,
put some sweat suits on and
just run to the grocery store.
I get to the aisle to pay, and
the woman behind the counter
said to me, do you want me
to put the items in the bag?
Do you want me to put
the items in the bag?
And a third time-- do you want
me to put the items in the bag?
I leaned back and I said,
that would be terrific.
Thank you very much.
She was so taken aback that
I spoke English fluently.
What did she see?
Second story.
When I was a VP at
TheLadders.com--
terrific company--
and we were looking
at some important software
and meeting with a vendor,
I slid in late to a
meeting, and my team
had started the meeting already.
There was an empty chair.
And as the vendor
was presenting,
I politely interrupted and
I asked a set of questions,
because this was an
important software
and it was an
important decision.
As I was in the midst of
a number of questions,
he paused, and he said to
me, I'm sorry, young lady.
Do you know anything about
the recruiting industry?
And I ignored it.
I smiled, and I continued
to ask my questions.
And I think by the
fifth set of questions,
he realized I was the decision
maker in the room with regards
to the software.
And I continued
to proceed and ask
the questions I wanted to ask.
A third story-- what did he see?
A third story-- a
very, very recent one.
We just took the company
public, and last year, we
did a non-deal roadshow as
part of the practice of taking
a company public, to get
institutional investor
feedback.
We had been flying around,
and I was exhausted.
I decided to go to
the bathroom quickly.
Get any bio breaks that you can.
And I came into the
meeting and went straight
for the coffee pot, because
there was very little sleep.
Our CTO was a man.
Our CFO was a man.
Proceeded to sit down, and of
course, I was at the coffee.
And I said to everybody--
I felt like my parents
and my mom raised me well--
and I offered everybody coffee.
When I went in line and started
making the introductions--
CTO said, hello,
my name is Dave,
CFO says, yes, my name
is John-- and then
when I was about to shake the
institutional investor's hand,
they said, you must
be the assistant.
And I smiled with a big
smile on my face, and I said,
I'm Sheila Marcelo.
I'm founder and CEO of Care.com.
Very nice to meet you.
Thanks for having me.
What did they see?
A lot of it really
starts up here.
And in those moments, I
put a big smile on my face,
and I have what I call
my Katniss moment.
How many of you have
seen "Hunger Games?"
It's those heroic moments.
Why do I go back to superheroes?
I go back to Clark
Kent, the newest one,
Henry Cavell-- really
hot, really cute.
But-- it was easier
to find his picture.
And Angelina Jolie, too.
So why these superheroes?
Because oftentimes,
superheroes are underestimated
because of that inner strength
that they have in here.
I'm a huge superhero fan.
I watch all of them.
So the question to
the audience is,
how many times have
you felt like you've
been underestimated?
Where does it start?
What do people see in you?
And so much of it
starts up here.
What's so interesting,
though, is
that it really starts
within ourselves.
Here, and here.
So much about it is about
reprogramming the brain.
And we're going to talk a
little bit about the brain.
And for a fact, if
you are suspect about
whether the brain
can be reprogrammed,
there have been lots of studies.
It's broken the myth that
brain development only
happens with children.
In fact, it's changed.
The studies have now shown
that even in your 40s--
I'm in my 40s-- you can
reprogram the brain.
There's a study
called neuroplasticity
that's coming out.
It's being applied
to leadership.
Some terrific books coming out.
Korn Ferry put one out
called "Learning Agility."
How do you continue to
learn and be flexible,
which is important leadership?
There's another great
book that I just
finished, called
"Immunity To Change."
And it is precisely
about the development
of the brain from three
phases-- self awareness,
self-authoring the brain
to change the framework
and how you think about
things, to what we
call self-transforming.
And we'll talk about those
three phases in a little bit.
So so much of it starts up here.
And I'm going to come back to
what I've had to reprogram.
Everybody has their
vowels and consonants
of whatever their shortcut is.
I have what I call my three P's.
My three P's are not the
typical MBA positioning,
packaging, pricing.
It is about perfection,
passivity, and pleasing.
Those are things I've had
to reprogram in my brain.
But I want to come back
to those and describe
that in a little
bit, after I describe
some of the things
around the journey
that I went through to
get to reprogramming.
Here's a quick journey
in describing my story.
A very good friend
of mine at work,
Erica Scheik, who is our
Chief Brand Officer--
as we prepare
speeches, sometimes she
looks for pictures on
Facebook, and I have no idea,
and she puts it up.
And she said, it seems
to me that whenever
I go on Facebook,
most of your pictures,
you seem to be at the
center of the picture.
What's going on with that?
I started to really unpack
what's going on there?
And I said, there
really is a story.
So guess what?
The little girl in the
polka dot, peeking out,
in red and white, is Sheila.
So at a very young
age, when I was three,
I got thrown into
the center-- I was
the fifth of six kids--
thrown into the center,
because we were in
the Philippines.
I was born and raised
in the Philippines.
We became-- a very
brief period-- colonized
by the Americans, and freed
us from Spanish oppression
for over 300 years.
So we were so enamored
by American English,
and of course the
music, and the Beatles,
and so my parents
said, we would love
for you to learn
American English.
And here I was at
three years old,
and I was forced to read
American newspapers in front
of all my relatives, starting
when I was three years old.
And constantly
put in the center.
And I learned early to have
my voice at such a young age,
and to public speak.
But like every child,
and especially-- I'm
making a stereotype, but a
large majority of teenage girls
go through their insecurity.
I went through my own.
In high school, I went
to boarding school.
I was 14, crying
to my sister who
also went to the same school.
She was three years
older than me.
I was in her room--
typical weekend--
crying, crying, talking
about this friend talking
behind my back, and could I
trust them, and what did I do,
and why was I
perceived this way?
And went on and on and on.
An hour later, my sister, who
was three years older-- at 17,
very, very wise--
said to me, we just
spent an hour talking about you.
So obviously, a
majority of your brain
is spent thinking about you.
What makes you think anybody
else thinks about you?
Because they think
about themselves.
So get over yourself.
Get over your insecurity.
They've got all other
problems in life.
We spent this entire hour, 90%
of the time, talking about you.
Other people are the same
way, so get over yourself.
Insecure teenager.
Fast forward, when
I get to college--
I went to Mount Holyoke
College, an all women's college.
I moved from the Philippines.
I went to a small liberal arts.
But still, I was an immigrant,
and it was foreign for me.
And I remember, at my very
first Asian American meeting,
I raised my hand
to ask a question.
I was shaking, and my whole
head was covered in sweat.
I was so nervous.
Where was the little girl?
What happened to her voice?
What happened?
What was going on in my brain?
Where was all this
anxiety coming from?
I pose those things
because I think
so many people have their
own stories of insecurities,
of things that
are going through,
whatever-- it's their
upbringing, whatever baggage,
or anything else.
But there is an opportunity
to reprogram your brain.
In my adulthood, I decided
to go on this journey.
I call it the me, you, we.
I haven't written
a book about it.
It's not anything fancy.
There's not any
marketing speak there.
But it's called the
journey of me, you, we.
I'm going to go through
that in a second.
But before I do that, I
wanted to give everybody
a heads up-- that after I
talk about the journey of me,
you, we, I want
to call two of you
up here, to share for one minute
with everybody, your Katniss
moment.
So think about it for a second,
and then I'll come back to you.
What is this journey
of me, you, we?
The first part of me
is very narcissistic.
It is about building
self-awareness.
You journal.
You ask yourself, whether it's
in a professional or personal
environment, what
are my triggers?
What is it in that meeting
that made me talk that way?
What point was I
trying to get across?
Was I trying to
be a team player,
or was I trying to shine
and be a superhero?
And I often ask those I
mentor across the company,
did you inspire
or did you impress
when you left that meeting?
Because at the end of the
day, what is it that matters?
What are those
triggers that we have?
And I'm talking about something
here in a professional setting,
in meetings.
What are my triggers at home?
What is it that makes
me fly off the handle?
What makes me shut down?
What is it that makes me
passive, and not engaged?
You actually have
to invest to get
to the second phase,
of the you phase.
And why is that?
Because the you phase
is all about leadership.
It's focusing on
others-- not me, but you.
How do I focus on you?
How can I ever focus
on you if I spend
90% of my brain
thinking about me?
Here's an image.
You're in a meeting.
How are you going
to run the meeting
to focus on the strategy,
the content, the body
language, the eye contact,
the subliminal messages that
are being sent around to
everybody in the room?
How are you running
that meeting if you're
spending 90% of your brain
focused on the insecurity of,
am I saying the right thing?
If I said this thing,
how am I being perceived?
How could you get
to that journey
of being a leader that focuses
on others if you're still
grappling with so many
things related to you?
So you have to invest
in that self-awareness.
I very much
encourage journaling.
And I've done that quite a bit.
I also very much
encourage meditation.
So it focuses a lot on
controlling your brain.
There's a great Buddhist
monk-- a modern book called
"Turning Your Mind
Into An Ally."
I read it every year.
It makes me pause, take a
step back, and really ask,
what is it that's going
through in my brain?
Is it the reality
of the situation,
or is it just my own stuff?
So that I can focus on you.
Another advice I
give-- and I often
give this to
management team members
who will come and relate a
story to me of something that's
difficult that's going
on in the company.
A specific management issue.
And I will pause,
and say, let's go
through-- I listen to
the whole story-- I said,
let's go through
that again, but now,
let's remove you
from the equation.
Let's pretend you
weren't even part
of the equation of
what happened there.
Let's just focus
on the employee,
and let's repeat
exactly what happened.
And the story fundamentally
shifts, and the thinking
shifts, in how we're going
to handle that situation.
Because now, it's not about
the actual person relating
this story, but it is about
the specific individual.
It's the you part.
And it's a powerful
thing to do that.
Another mnemonic I
always give people
is, when you're in a situation
and your body language starts
to shift, and your
heart rate, and this
is that investment
in you, and you
know your triggers-- what you
do is, you leave your body.
I'm not proselytizing Buddhism.
I'm not Buddhist.
You leave your body
and watch yourself.
You literally watch
yourself, and say,
what is it that's
going on there?
What is the real conversation
that's happening?
What are we trying to get
across from each other,
removing myself
from the equation,
so I can go solve the problems?
Now let's talk
about the we part.
And by the way, going
from me to you to we,
you can go back and forth.
The we part is very Gandhi-like.
It's from what we call
success to significance.
It's a very long
journey in life.
Because you focus on yourself.
You focus on the others, and
the people, and the lives
that you touch.
The we part is a hard one.
Because how do you impact
the lives of people
that you don't come
into connection with?
How do you create an impact
and significance in the world?
How do you focus
on the broader we
of the things that you
decide to do in life
or what you represent
in terms of leadership?
It's a journey I'm still
trying to figure out.
And by the way, this
journey is not an easy one.
You go back and
forth constantly,
learning about yourself, being
better, as a leader, to others.
And then, at the
same time, how am I
making an impact in the
world, and what am I
doing every day that
makes a big difference?
I call that the
journey of me, you, we.
Now, I'm going to call
in a couple people.
Volunteers are also welcomed,
but sometimes the cold call
is the only way to
get you up here.
I'm just kidding.
How did that feel?
Where was your heart rate?
More importantly, where
was your eye contact?
You probably were
not looking at me,
because you did not want
to get cold called on.
So how are you going
to run a meeting?
It sounds pretty basic, but
how do you master your mind
to manage the content?
Worry about perceptions?
Worry about impressing people?
It's just so much
to think about.
And that was just
a simple exercise.
That was just asking for a
minute-long Katniss moment.
It was your own personal story.
Some people are breathing hard.
Here's a technique.
This is my sister.
I shared that story.
This is a technique-- I wish
that I came up with this,
but this, actually, I
just picked up at a spa.
I went to cure myself.
I talked about the
narcissistic me.
It's called the
4-7-8, and it's one
of the most important business
techniques I try and teach
a lot of people.
You breathe in four times.
Do it with me.
You hold for seven, and you
breathe out eight counts.
You do it in cycles
of four times.
Guaranteed, your heart
rate will come down,
and lizard brain will go away,
and you will get centered,
and you will focus on
whatever it is you're doing.
You will be present.
I do it all the time.
I'm sitting here
right before I speak,
right before I have to go
on national television,
right before I run a
meeting, when I'm upset,
pissed off, driving in a car
and a driver is irritating me--
the 4-7-8 is like magic.
It's how do you create
that present in the moment
to stay focused and have
control of your brain.
Just a quick example.
There's plenty of
those exercises.
That's one I picked
up at Canyon Ranch.
It's terrific.
Why am I even talking about the
brain, and why does it matter,
and where is my
story in all of this?
So now, let's come
back to self-awareness,
and describe me in a second.
Two things-- how did
I let go of these P's
that I described early
in the beginning?
The first one is perfection.
Born and raised Asian family.
My mom was a tiger mom,
and I'm very proud of it,
because she was very aggressive
and pushed me to be assertive,
but also programmed
a lot of things
in me that I just
really needed to let go.
An example of this is-- and
many women might relate to this
or not-- but why is
it that on weekends I
have to have the dishes
put away before I even
enjoy the weekend?
Why do I nag my teenage
boy that the bed
has to be perfectly made?
He's giving this look
like, does it matter?
Because I've got to get
back in it tonight, anyways.
And my husband will come to
me, let's just enjoy the day.
Why don't you let go of that?
And I found, psychologically,
it was probably
the same set of
triggers at work.
Because when I was asked to
be promoted to a director,
I felt like all these boxes
hadn't been checked yet.
So when I got offered to be a
director, I looked at my boss,
I said, are you sure?
I don't know that I'm ready.
Of course, a man would get
an offer and say, sure.
I'd take that job.
But it happened, also, when I
got promoted to a VP, to a GM,
and then when I
asked to be a CEO.
What was it?
Is it because
that, for every job
that I take, that I have to
have the perfect experience?
That I've ticked
off all the boxes
before I'm ready for that job?
I knew that's not the case.
I know it seems like I'm using
a simple analogy, like dishes.
But what was it about my
own definition of perfection
that I had to let go?
That I had to have confidence
that I could do that job?
That I could just enjoy the
day and enjoy the moment?
So much of it really
does start up here.
A second, that was difficult
for me for a long time to learn,
is, how do I embrace
my strengths?
How do I own that the
differences are my strengths?
What do I mean by that?
I am a female leader, and I
do consider myself different.
There's nothing wrong
being different.
Diversity is a great thing.
But there's a big debate
among female leaders
that if you called yourself
out as a female leader,
it would mean that
you're different.
But isn't the whole
purpose of parity
to say that you're
not different?
That you're perfectly equal?
I don't think that's what it
means about gender equality
or parity.
I think it's about owning
that our differences are
our strengths.
It's a mouthful.
Let me say that again-- owning
that our differences are
our strengths.
That they really are strengths.
And what I call opposing forces.
You can be both
creative and analytical.
And what I used to be insecure
about, as a young leader,
professionally, was, can you
be both tough and nurturing?
I didn't used to bring
my whole self to work.
At home, if I'm
on the cell phone
and my son is nagging me to
go play a video game while I'm
distracted on the
phone, what look
do you think I'm giving him?
I'm, like, really?
Right now?
But I never question myself
that I can tuck him in bed
and be loving and nurturing
and still be tough.
Why can't I bring my whole
self to whatever I do?
That authentic self?
That those opposing
forces are still me?
Both sides are me.
Both sides can be strengths.
And there's so many
examples of that.
Back in the book
"Immunity to Change,"
the self-transforming mind
appreciates those opposing
forces.
That it's OK.
You don't have to
be one or the other.
You don't have to have one box
checked for that perfection.
Second P-- pleasing.
I grew up with these
designated professions
that I talked about.
Asian.
So there was a doctor--
there are six of us--
a doctor, a dentist,
an engineer, a lawyer,
an accountant.
My younger brother
got away with it.
He could do whatever
he wanted to.
But I was a designated lawyer.
So I decided to
apply to law school.
I got in.
I didn't enjoy my first
year of law school.
I liked the study
of it, but I didn't
think that I wanted
to be a lawyer.
So I applied, I got
into business school.
And my parents
really discouraged me
from becoming an
entrepreneur, because they
were entrepreneurs.
I was so focused
on pleasing them.
At the end the day,
I followed my heart.
It wasn't an easy task.
Because as an Asian, it
wasn't part of our culture
to do something different from
what my parents envisioned.
But to this day, I respectfully
said to them, look,
I will finish law school,
but I will not practice law,
and I will be an entrepreneur.
I followed my heart.
That was my second P.
The third is passivity.
I talked about being a
child that had a voice,
but yet, when I started
my professional career,
I went into either
the shyness or it
took some time to
actually speak up.
Law school certainly helped
for me to go and debate,
but I had to push
myself in meetings.
And then what ended up
happening-- and some of you
might nod your head on this--
is I started to, what I call,
over-project.
I forced myself so much to
be assertive in a meeting,
that it sounded
borderline aggressive.
Maybe not even
borderline at times.
I was young on the
management team.
I was in my 20's, and they were
all in their 50's at Upromise.
I was a petite Asian woman.
I didn't feel like I
was going to be heard.
And there were only two
of us, and the other woman
was also a petite lady.
And we both just spoke up.
And I called it over-projecting.
And I had to push
myself, because I
had an inherent
nature to be passive.
Nowadays, when I have young
management team members
or executives in the company,
I encourage over-projection
so much that I try
and speak last.
I try and encourage
going around the room
to try and encourage
people to find their voice.
That it's OK.
But how do you conquer that
if you don't practice it?
How do you conquer and
reprogram your brain
so that you can feel confidently
listening to yourself?
You've got to just
put yourself out
there and let go
of that shyness.
So that's the me three P's.
And everyone has got their
vowels or consonants.
Whatever summary that
you've got of what
you think you need to reprogram?
It is very doable.
The second is the you
part, this helping others.
How many of you consider
yourself leaders?
Raise your hand.
Awesome.
Google is awesome.
How many of you consider
yourself female leaders?
Half.
It's usually 10% when
I ask that question.
And why is that?
Again, it's that debate
that I talked about.
What I think really
needs to happen
is, if you are a female leader,
because there's few of us,
is raise your hand up high
and let other people see you.
We need more role models.
Believe that.
Believe that you
are a role model
to so many girls
and young women who
need to follow in your
footsteps, to lead.
But raise it up proudly.
And it's OK.
There's nothing wrong
being different.
It's about diversity.
And I always often
hear the comment
that women hate going
to women's conferences
now, because what do
you get out of it?
It's the power and strength
of meeting other women.
Not all of them are
effective, I understand.
But if it means being able to
share stories with each other,
to conquer whatever it
is you're reprogramming,
and to get tips from each other,
I highly, highly encourage it.
That's each to his
own, obviously.
Or her own.
So I do think that
that's important.
And then, how do we get
more of these stories out?
Walter Isaacson of
the Aspen Institute
just put out the book
on the innovators.
And I think some of you probably
read the most recent "New York
Times" article.
I don't know if you know
that Ada Lovelace was
one of the first who ever
wrote a computer algorithm.
It's actually in his
forward of his book,
because his daughter
wrote a paper on it,
and that's the only time he
even heard of Ada Lovelace.
I don't know if
you've heard of it.
I only read it in the
"New York Times" article.
And it dawned on
me-- why don't we
have more stories
of female leaders
out there, so that we
can create role models?
More stories about you.
Get it out there.
Share it with others.
Blog.
Not because you're selfish
or you're self-promoting,
but because you do
want to make an impact.
Now let me get to the we.
I have not forgotten
the men in the room.
I don't want you to think I'm
just talking to the women.
I'm looking at the guys.
I'm going to talk
about my son, Adam.
He is 14 years old.
He plays nose tackle football.
He's also starting
to really smell.
And shave.
Shower is the constant
debate in our household.
But he is also this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ADAM SINGS]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
He's also an opera boy.
He now sings baritone.
That was obviously treble
soprano, and he was younger.
His voice is getting deeper
and deeper, so it saddens me.
But he's also a football player.
One day he comes
home from school,
and I said, how
was your day, bud?
And he looked pretty troubled.
And he said, Mom,
I have to tell you,
I'm just really irritated
with my football friends.
They don't want me to sit with
my drama friends and kids that
sing.
And they're like, why are
you always singing, too?
Kind of picking on
him, and irritated.
He's 5'10", and
he's kind of big,
so it's hard to pick on him, but
he was really bothered by that.
So I was ready to jump in, be
the mom, to solve that moment,
give him advice, and
he said, I got it.
I got this one.
I said, what do you mean?
He said, I don't
really care what
they're saying about
my drama friends.
I love the books we read.
I love the
conversations we have.
They're terrific.
I must tell you, I felt pride.
I felt hope that I had
taught my son to woman up.
He had embraced those
opposing forces.
Both the diversity and all
the different strengths,
whether he's learned
it from his dad or me.
And why do I share this?
Because both men and
women in the room,
what are we doing to
reprogram our brain?
What are we doing to woman up?
Thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: How much
of these values
are you imbuing into the
company that you're leading,
and that you're building?
And how are you doing that?
How are you getting your
leadership team, and all
of your employees, to embrace
these values that you clearly
hold so dearly?
SHEILA MARCELO: Well,
certainly we put out values
across the board that are gender
neutral for the entire company.
It's there for you--
transparency, humility,
excellence, respectfulness,
and entrepreneurship.
That's the there part.
So it's important, I
think, to articulate values
from the very beginning, even
in the formation of the company.
The other thing that I do on
the gender-specific question
is that I very much am
comfortable with naming that,
is there a gender issue
that's going on here?
And it may or may
not, but at least
opening the dialogue,
so it's something
that we can just talk through.
I had once one executive
on the management team
who would sometimes
lose his temper.
It happened a few times.
And I had to pause in a
101 intermeeting and say,
is it because I'm
a female leader?
Let's talk about that.
It's not necessarily comfortable
to have those conversations,
but I think it's
important and it's
necessary to improve
those relationships.
Because the reality
is, I am a woman.
When you take your
Myers-Briggs, and you're
extroverted or introverted,
you're a feeler or a judger,
or whatever those letters
are, that's who you are.
So if it's impacting the
relationship and the way
we lead the company,
then we need
to have those conversations.
AUDIENCE: Sheila, thank you
for sharing your stories.
I could relate to a lot of them.
One question-- so as you
move from a management career
into entrepreneurship,
could you talk
a little bit about that journey
and how it went for you?
SHEILA MARCELO: I think that I
had been an entrepreneur ever
since I was little,
because I started
helping my mom in her business
at six or seven years old,
to answer phones,
and I was known
to ask lots and
lots of questions
about how business functions.
Why do we price that way?
So I think it was just inherent.
But I think-- you can
have entrepreneurship.
And it is, to me, the
values of risk-taking.
The values of testing
and iterating constantly.
To say, it's OK to fail, embrace
that as a learning moment,
as opposed to being
judged as a failure.
So I think that it's
having those set of values
that makes someone an
entrepreneur, whether you're
in a large company or where
you're starting something.
It is that embracing
failure, taking risk,
pushing yourself to disrupt
yourself-- to be innovative.
Just recently, we took
the company public.
But I would say the fall prior
to taking the company public,
I had asked the
question of everybody
on the management team, how
do we disrupt ourselves?
Are we the right
team to scale this?
And I had a few management team
members actually come up to me
and say, I'm not sure
I'm the right person
to scale at this level.
And to have that conversation--
because again, it's
that entrepreneur, to say,
how do we disrupt, how do we
innovate, even with ourselves,
whenever it's necessary?
AUDIENCE: What advice can you
share when you inadvertently
intimidate people in
your professional growth?
SHEILA MARCELO: I think
that the intimidation can--
oftentime comes across in style.
It can also come across in the
intelligence and the quickness
to get to the
heart of the issue.
So it's understanding what
is your style in triggering
others, and starting
to journal about it.
It doesn't mean
changing who you are.
But it may be the case
that sometimes intimidation
is because you're quick to jump
to exactly what the answer is,
as opposed to bringing and
influencing other people along.
And posing intelligent
questions that
allows them to come up with
their own ideas and answers.
It's less intimidating,
and actually you're
viewed more as a
leader, because you're
inspiring them to come
up with their own ideas,
though you may have
already thought about it.
And because if you're
intelligent enough
to know what the answer
is 10 steps later,
you're also intelligent enough
to understand that sometimes,
you've got to figure out the
steps to guide them there.
So it really depends on the
situation of the intimidation.
It could be stylistic.
It could be your voice.
It could be the way you dress.
And it's trying to
really figure that out,
and making sure that
your journaling about it.
I graduated JD MBA from Harvard,
and I went to a startup,
and I was a product manager.
And whenever I got
introduced, it automatically
would create this intimidation.
In fact, years ago,
I told my friend
that when she
applied for a job--
she was also a JD MBA-- I was,
like, just leave the JD out.
That was really
the wrong advice.
And now, in hindsight, it's
about altering your style.
Not changing yourself,
but understanding
how to relate better to other
people to also help guide them.
You don't want to act
dumb if you're not dumb.
You know what I mean?
Be smart.
That's a strength.
AUDIENCE: My question is simple.
I think we focus
on-- we're trying
to look to others to see
how we're influencing them,
how we're inspiring.
Who actually inspires you?
Who do you look up to?
SHEILA MARCELO:
Certainly my mother.
Because when she
was in her mid 20s,
she had six children already.
So when I used to complain--
I would say, I'm so tired,
I'm doing all this.
My mother would give me
this look-- like, honey,
you have no idea.
And she was an entrepreneur.
And they just celebrated-- and
I just shared it with a friend,
right before this--
they just celebrated
their 50th anniversary.
And so my parents'
love truly inspires me,
and their loyalty to each other.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Sheila.
I had a question
about-- you briefly
spoke about the
Impostor Syndrome
that so many women go
through and you even felt.
What are some ways that
you could tell us about,
or you even go through,
to overcome that?
SHEILA MARCELO: I
have touched on this.
The Impostor Syndrome, clinical
psychologists have found,
actually skews a lot
higher with women.
This whole
self-doubt, especially
if you're in a specific
position, thinking,
I'm really not-- what I did
years ago was, I journaled.
You probably have gone
through this instance where
you're in a meeting and
you thought of an idea
and you could have shared
it, but then somebody else
mentioned it 10 minutes later.
I started to look
for affirmations
of, really, my knowledge.
Affirmations that
gave me confidence
that I wasn't really
being an impostor.
If I was an impostor, why
would I come up with that idea?
Why did I lead that strategy?
A good friend of mine,
she reminded me years
ago to write three things
that really went well,
that patted myself on
the back every day.
Those gratifying moments.
And it's not,
again, to be showy,
and to drink my own Kool-Aid.
It really is, what three
things meant a lot to me that
affirmed who I
was, what impact I
was making on the
world and unto others,
and really journaling
about it three times.
And it's a self-fulfilling
thing that just gives you
a lot more belief
and confidence.
And just keep
going back to that.
It actually really works in
reprogramming your brain.
It's just like exercising
and working out.
And it becomes a behavior
thing that changes.
So that whenever you have
those negative thoughts
and those impostor thoughts
go in through your brain,
but because you journal about
it so much and you re-read it,
you go back and look
at it so that you're
doing it real time
at that point.
So you've just
reprogrammed your brain
to say that negative
thought, that Sheila voice?
Get out of there.
I don't need it.
I've got other really good
thoughts going on right now.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: To follow up on that
discussion of the impostor,
and also having your
Superwoman moments,
you have an amazing resume
and amazing credentials.
So it's really wonderful
to have someone--
to put them in the their
place, and have someone
say, oh, you must
be the assistant,
and then you can turn around
and say, I'm actually the CEO.
How about for women
who need to go
through certain
amounts of preparation
or feel like they need to get
certain credentials before they
can have those moments?
What advice would you have
for the pre-CEO moment?
And then also,
how do you balance
between being perfect and
having the preparation
and feeling confident and just
having your Superwoman moment?
SHEILA MARCELO: That's
a really good question.
It is that finding
that authenticity
that-- I actually
went through it.
Of course, everybody
had a pre-CEO moment.
I was a young VP
at Upromise, and we
had a partnership with
an external partner.
And the VP on the other end was
much more experienced than me,
and was questioning
whether or not
my leadership on
this integration
was the right assignment that
the CEO at Upromise gave.
And I remember going to the CEO
in tears-- he still teases me
about this meeting--
in tears, saying,
how do I handle this situation?
How do I get respected?
I'm working in my butt off,
and I'm working really hard,
and why am I not
getting the respect?
His name is George
Bell, and continues
to be my mentor to this day,
and said to me, you have to--
and we've heard
this before-- you
have to earn that respect by not
necessarily-- it's not a stamp.
It's how you carry
yourself from here.
And this, to this day, has
stayed with me, this advice.
How do you bring out that
authentic, bold self?
That inner confidence?
Doesn't matter what
your resume is.
That you don't need
to drink the Kool-Aid
to feel good about yourself.
What is it that's in here?
And people around you feel it.
They feel this inner strength
and this inner confidence,
because it's real.
But it is a journey
to get there.
And in leadership, people
want to be around you,
because you're authentic you.
And it doesn't matter
where I went to school.
None of that matters,
because it means
that I treat everybody the
same way-- with respect.
Listening.
And so, it's about
you, and building that.
We've got a young
woman in the company--
exceptionally bright,
incredibly charismatic.
And I said to her, you bring
so much of that charisma.
But she's over-projecting
right now,
because she's trying to figure
out, how do I influence?
And one of the things
we're talking about
is, what's that inner
authentic boldness?
Do I have the answers for
you specifically about that?
No.
You're going to have
to journal about it.
But I've given her
the goal to say,
what is that inner authentic
boldness that's you,
that comes out and it shines?
And you'll find that
when you find that,
you'll have a skip in
your step, and you'll
know that that's you.
And it is a journey.
And I think some
of you are nodding.
And it's not easy.
But journal about it.
Journal about the great moments
when you came out of a meeting
and say, God, I got that right.
That went well.
That felt good.
Why?
What happened?
How did you carry yourself?
How were you listening?
How did you
summarize the points?
Did you speak last?
Did you worry less
about what you
were trying to impress
everybody in the room,
but instead you did such a
great job truly leading it
that then everybody felt
good, and you felt good?
What are those moments,
and how do you repeat them?
And they become behavioral
changes in your style.
And that just takes time.
And it is a journey.
MODERATOR: Sheila, you talked
about moving from success--
which you've clearly achieved--
to significance, which it seems
like you're really
doing, by participating
in these conversations
that you're
having with leaders
of countries.
I'm curious to learn more
about the White House
Summit, and what your goals
were in participating in that,
and anything that you
experienced or learned there.
SHEILA MARCELO: Yeah, sure.
A friend of mine,
Tina Brown, was
in the audience-- I just
saw her this past weekend--
and complimented me
for being on stage
to share our mission at Care.
And it is to
professionalize care giving.
And because I believe
in it so much.
I was born and raised
in the Philippines,
and so many
caregivers-- and this
is beyond the Philippines--
but so many caregivers
are from the Philippines,
and from developed countries
around the world.
And sometimes I'm in
professional settings,
and I remind people
that these women give up
their lives and their own
children in their home
countries to take
care of your children.
And that is a big,
big sacrifice.
And how do we
professionalize that?
How do we make sure
that they're valued?
And why do I care?
Not just in business
terms, but because we
will have serious
societal issues.
We will have a shortage of care.
But it's also a
great business thing.
Because if we have
shortage of caregivers,
then of course Care.com
is not going to grow.
But it's not the main
reason that I got into this.
I got into this because
I have such this passion
and this belief of making
sure that we are treating them
with respect.
So with the White House, it is
about everything-- addressing
minimum wage, specifically, and
professionalizing care giving.
Home Pay, which is the
largest household payroll tax
company, that we
run at Care.com.
How do we make it
clear that families
should pay above board, to
provide their caregivers
benefits?
And then on the family side,
how do you, as an employee,
make sure that you're getting
the benefits that you need?
Because so much-- and
I've explained this
to world leaders,
and they get it--
is that, what drives
GDP growth is jobs.
And if you want
more women to work,
you must invest in a
care infrastructure,
whether you're the government
or whether you're employers.
If we want diversity in the
workplace, you must have care.
Because there is
such a co-dependency.
You can't go to work if you
don't have peace of mind
at home.
And you can't afford great
care unless you're working.
They've got to work to make
sure that that happens.
So that combination is something
that-- it's a powerful mission
that we have at Care.com.
AUDIENCE: You talk about
pleasing, perfection,
and passivity, and it's clear
that your pinayness shows
through those P's.
SHEILA MARCELO:
Pinayness is a Filipina.
AUDIENCE: It's a Filipina.
How are you convincing
pinays to pinay up?
SHEILA MARCELO: I'm
actually doing quite a bit
in the Philippines.
I'm on the Philippine
Development Foundation.
I also help put
together a female CEO
group in the Philippines.
We're up about 100 now.
Whenever I go home to
the Philippines, which
is about three times
a year, we regroup.
I was just there
to talk about it.
I'm also convincing
them-- anybody
who is interested in
working on a project
like this-- to develop-- do
you remember that "Got Milk?"
campaign?
I'm always advocating this.
You have celebrities
to drink milk,
and the dairy industry can
afford it, and it's great.
One of the things
is, the Philippines
is one of the countries in Asia
with the narrowest gender gap.
It's the only Asian
country in the top 10,
where the Scandinavian
countries are, because there's
a cultural heritage around
a very matriarchal society.
And I have heard Japanese
women speak, to say,
when we see Filipino
women, it inspires us
that we can ourselves lead.
So one of the things
I'm trying to encourage
the Asian countries,
especially the Philippines,
is to showcase these role
models of female leadership.
To woman up.
To raise your hand up high.
To develop this "Got
Milk?" campaign.
We've got an agency
in the Philippines.
We're starting to
think about it.
It's a fun project.
But how do we encourage more
women to help other women?
As Madeleine Albright
said, there's
a place in hell for women
who don't help other women.
MODERATOR: OK.
So, I think-- oh, there's
one last question.
OK.
AUDIENCE: It's clear that
you've gone from one success
to another.
I'm very curious to
see, what do think of
as success in your own life?
What keeps you motivated
to go after the next thing?
And if you ever
feel like, I'm done?
SHEILA MARCELO: No.
The key drivers for me
is really my family.
The key successes for me is
milestone-- I got pregnant
at a very young age.
And seeing my son
graduate from college
is a very big deal for
my husband and I. Seeing
my parents-- they
also got married
when they were teenagers.
They hit their
50-year milestone,
and now we're 35 in the clan.
Those are the things that keep
my North Star, keep me focused.
I have this policy that I
don't talk about Care at home,
and I don't talk about
it with my family.
So that I'm not drinking
my own Kool-Aid.
I am just Sheila,
everywhere I go
that I spend time with
my family and friends.
That it is not about the
company, or the definition
of what we're doing.
Because at Care,
it is actually what
we're doing for others, as
opposed to some leadership
position that I'm getting
some fulfillment out of.
[APPLAUSE]